now we focus again on the recent mass
shootings around the country in one
city's effort to stop the violence
earlier this month a shootout in one of
philadelphia's busiest neighborhoods
killed three people and injured 11
others the number of gun violence
victims in that city increased by more
than 50 percent from 2019 to 2020. last
year philly had more than 2 300 shooting
victims and this year that number is
already above 1 000. our national
correspondent jerica duncan recently
embedded with a team of pastors and
volunteers to see how the community is
responding
thank you all for coming out tonight to
our corners to connections initiative
it's night 10. on this friday night and
every night this month in the shadow of
darkness
and flashing lights 37 year old pastor
ji lamar stewart organizes faith leaders
and volunteers it happened to me on
juneteenth
of 2021 my 23 year old son evan baylor
was gunned down in front of my house
this is a 30 day violence interruption
initiative to walk through philadelphia
neighborhoods plagued by gun violence
group one lisa group two
kelly group three split in different
groups these 22 violence interrupters
patrol the streets from 9 to 11. how's
everybody doing tonight introducing
themselves to neighbors and handing out
flyers about an upcoming job fair we're
having a job fair on the 30th if you
know anybody looking for work
boom
people have kids young
so they don't know what to do we turn
around try to find somewhere to work
trying to get you know get a job and
it's hard for us you know just because
of the color of our skin and we're out
here beating these streets being this
payment
because we believe in your generation
and that's the main goal to directly
meet and reach as many young black men
as possible the ones most at risk of
falling victim to the streets people are
used to someone maybe coming up saying
here's some information putting a flyer
in their hand
but what
young people need is a constant presence
and someone who's gonna follow up what
should we be doing to help your
generation
one
avoid the life of the streets
and two to help get you all where you
want to be
i mean me personally i said like try to
get like the youth to try to get into uh
like different activities i met a group
of people similarly to you you know what
i'm saying that came up to me you know
and they didn't stop you know what i'm
saying like i rejected them first time
but they didn't stop you know i'm saying
so
it's always good to know that you still
care i lost my son the same age as you
so it's important to to hear
what can we do or what can be done how
are you able to garner that strength to
come out here there are some days that
are very difficult like his birthday
devastating people who keep committing
these heinous crimes understand that
while you took a life that you may have
been mad about that day look at the
people that you leave behind and can you
look at them in the face
like whoever took my son's life can they
look me in the face and say that it was
okay to do that no it's not
eighteen-year-old wayne lee prouder the
third graduated from high school just
hours earlier instead of celebrating he
came out to volunteer i'm out here
because i'm sick of it i'm tired of it
we shouldn't have to do this it's like
we can't keep depending on our older
generation it's time for
this generation
to actually step up
and do what they have to do
you know these are our kids these are
our nephews these are our sons um these
are our daughters our nieces
and we understand that we have a
responsibility as a church in church
community we have a responsibility as a
society to
wrap our arms around them do you ever
lose hope i may lose hope in man
but i never lose hope in god
i may lose hope in government
but i may never lose hope in god
those volunteers say they plan to
continue their efforts throughout the
summer maybe not every night like right
now in the month of june but they're
committed the 30 days on the streets
though culminates with a job fair at the
end of this month you guys know that the
situation in philadelphia is dire
the number of shootings they've had over
200 people have lost their lives and
there's so many people that have a
connection whether it is a son a
daughter an uncle
a niece etc so
this is um
a small part of the bigger problem in
terms of what could be done but i think
you you can feel that these people
they're tired they're sick you can talk
about programs you can talk about policy
right they're actually doing the work
that's why i like people like wayne
who's young i know that i am sick and
tired and that's why i'm out here and
that's what it's going to take young
people rising up and saying enough and
the pastor who said he may lose hope in
man and government but he doesn't lose
hope in god yeah a lot of work to do
there